you wrote in your book that you you had
Sexual Energy with some of the
housewives like Tamra yeah I know you're
not interested in women but what is this
Sexual Energy you have well and I was
trying to figure that out because she of
course I heard from Tamara after and she
was like so what's happening with us
like what is this and look she has shown
me every incarnation of her breasts of
her bare breasts she has that one point
or another flashed me shown me as the I
mean uh so and then we also I remembered
I hosted a live New Year's Eve debacle
on uh Bravo one year I think the 2011
into 2012. and I think she and I made
out at midnight on the air in front of
her husband so like it's not I'm not
pulling that out of a hat necessarily
what is that do you think it's that
women are titillated by their gay friend
and feel comfortable enough to show
their tits yeah I think there's
definitely a safety and God knows I've
asked her about her breasts enough that
I'm sure at some point she was like well
let me just show you I'm sure if I was
straight
maybe she wouldn't have done that
because absolutely not yeah exactly
um I feel fortunate to be able to you
know be a part of the discussion and and
and and and you're probably you've
probably seen that a million times as a
gay man you've probably seen women go oh
I'm going to show you my tits oh Andy I
want to buy blood like they get sexual
around you and I'm not sure what that is
psychologically wouldn't you have
um bragging rights if you were the one
that was uh you know
that I was like okay let's let's just do
this
yeah I guess I don't feel like if there
was some straight guy who presented
himself to me and if there was a Stern
Show fan I'm gonna put it out there who
came to me and said Andy
I've never done anything with the dude
but you're my man
I would feel a certain way I would feel
like wow this is this is a compliment
how great yes why did you write that
Sonya Morgan is the most outrageous
housewife I mean she's wild are these
people Wild for the camera
people always say what are the
housewives like in real life and I say
if you run into a housewife in the wild
they will be exactly as they appear on
the show I mean you you know Ramona
Singer lives in I think semi in your
radius out east and if you ever ran into
her Beth would probably say wow I mean
wow what wow get away from her or wow
didn't lie this is not anything she is
as she is
thank you